some of you may be familiar with my
assistant sona yeah she's always wasting
time at work rather than helping me her
boss yeah yeah for example and this is
real true story she recently re-watched
all 10 seasons of friends while at work
yes
yes she did nothing for me but rewatched
all 10 seasons and friends
well now it's the holiday season so sona
is busier than ever doing her own
personal stuff on company time luckily
one of our sponsors came to the rescue
and they gave Sona a Google pixel for
phone with the new Google assistant to
help her and me survive the holidays
take a look oh hey Sona could you send
someone to get my dry cleaning sure
thank hey Google buy me sushi
restaurants that deliver lunch I found a
few sushi restaurants near you done
thank you
hey Sona could you text Andy make sure
he got the invitation to my Christmas
party yep hey Google call mom hi mom I
just started a princess for Christmas
it's really good thanks for telling me
about it okay okay bye
Oh son I want to take the crew out to
lunch on Friday someplace really nice
thank him for all the hard work they've
done this year spare no expense can you
make a reservation yeah okay great
thanks hey Google remind me to buy milk
tonight at 7:00 p.m.
hey let's bring her out my assistant so
nice
[Applause]
as soon as we can see you truly are
terrible at your job congratulate I
don't know about that yeah yeah I think
I'm the assistant you desert yes you cut
us don't touch me by the way I want to
point out that was sown as real mom on
the phone isn't that right son yeah yeah
okay this is fun here are some outtakes
these are real of sona trying to coach
her mom I'm performing in the sketch but
mom's supposed to pick up mom's supposed
to pick up the phone I know but but but
we're shooting something can she just
call Australia back it's too late mom I
have to call back all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna call you back in just a few
minutes where I'm gonna do it a few
times okay just you say you've normal
like how you pick up and then I'm gonna
say oh I started a princess for
Christmas thanks for telling me about it
and then you go oh good or old great hi
hi mom I just started a princess for
Christmas it's really good thanks for
telling me about it Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
my my dad was talking to the uncle that
told you that to lose weight you can't
buy that
hey thanks all of our friends at Google
and Estonia we have a great Center like
me and Ron Funches